Justice League, the latest installment in
the DCEU, is here, and there's plenty to unpack
once the two hour super-slugfest has ended.
We've got tons of classic characters finally
making their real debuts, we've got teases
for future movies in the franchise — we've
got the Flash falling down a lot and Batman
cracking jokes.
"What are your super powers again?"
"I'm rich."
What more could you want?
Well, how about an explanation as to what
that ending was about?
Without further ado, let's take a dive into
the cinematic waters and explain the ending
of Justice League.
And just in case you were wondering: spoilers
ahead.
Steppenwolf steps out
So the Justice League has finally made its
way to the big screen.
DC Comics' biggest and best superhero team
has formed, and they've teamed up to fight
the classic comics villain...Steppenwolf.
Yes, everyone's favorite bad guy, Steppenwolf.
Wait, you never heard of Steppenwolf?
Well, don't worry.
Most folks haven't.
To be honest, even most comic book nerds would
be hard pressed to tell you who, exactly,
Steppenwolf is.
All you really need to know is that he's one
of the less exciting henchpeople serving under
one of DC's biggest bad guys, Darkseid, who
rules over the crappy planet Apokolips.
When Steppenwolf got mobbed by his own Parademon
soldiers at the end of the movie, he boom
tubed his way off of Earth.
Where'd he go?
Well, there's a good bet he went back home
to tell Darkseid that he'd failed to turn
Earth into a new version of Apokolips with
the three Mother Boxes.
Speaking of which...
New New Genesis
It's never quite clear what, exactly the three
Mother Boxes are going to do to Earth once
they...well, once they whatever it is they
were doing before Cyborg and Superman split
them apart.
But the comics that inspired elements of the
movie might hold some clues.
While Darkseid and Steppenwolf hang out on
the dank, always-engulfed-in-flames planet
of Apokolips, they're also at war with their
opposite: New Genesis.
For those who don't know, New Genesis is basically
the jam, and everyone there is super happy
all the time.
In short: New Genesis is good, Apokolips is
bad.
Anyway, it's heavily implied that Steppenwolf's
plan to merge the three Mother Boxes would
result in Earth becoming a new version of
Apokolips for Darkseid to rule over.
And when Cyborg and Superman separated the
three Mother Boxes, the area surrounding the
climactic battle bloomed to life with strange,
alien flowers.
There isn't a whole lot of information to
help us understand what, exactly, happened
there at the end.
But could it be that separating the boxes
had the opposite effect?
Maybe instead of Earth turning into a New
Apokolips, we instead got a glimpse of New
New Genesis...or maybe the filmmakers just
wanted to make that crummy area around the
nuclear reactor look nice after the super
people got done punching each other.
Either one.
A league of their own
The very end of the movie saw the return of
Jesse Eisenberg's Lex Luthor, not to mention
the first movie appearance of Slade Wilson,
better known as Deathstroke.
When the two meet up on Luthor's yacht, the
bald nerd says that he'd like to establish
a league of his own.
And yes, you're not wrong to think he's making
reference to everyone's favorite movie about
ladies playing baseball in the '40s — but
he's not.
Sorry.
In fact, he's referring to a group of supervillains
who, in the comics, would band together to
try and take over the world from time to time.
These bad guys have gone through plenty of
different rosters and names over the years:
the Injustice League, the Injustice Gang,
the Legion of Doom, One Direction — we don't
know which name they'll pick when they make
their return in future DCEU films.
But they'll have plenty of heroes to fight.
Room for more?
Near the very end credits, Bruce, Diana, and
Alfred take a tour of the dilapidated old
Wayne Manor and start planning their new Justice
League clubhouse — or Hall of Justice, if
you will.
Bruce mentions a big round table with six
seats, while Diana adds, "with room for more."
Naturally, this implies that more superpowered
folks will be joining the DCEU soon.
It's probably a bit too soon to say who, exactly,
will add their chairs to the table, we do
have some clues.
For instance, Warner Bros. has a Shazam! movie
in the works, not to mention another run at
adapting the Green Lantern characters to the
big screen.
There are plenty of DC characters who will
supposedly join the members of the Justice
League at the big table in the not so distant
future.
Well, probably.
Now, while we're on that subject, let's discuss...
The future of the DCEU
While Justice League will certainly earn a
whole lot of money for Warner Bros., there
are larger questions at work regarding the
future of the DC Extended Universe.
For instance, out of the five movies that
comprise the cinematic universe, only one
— Wonder Woman — managed to earn a certified
fresh rating from review aggregator Rotten
Tomatoes.
Like Man of Steel, Batman v Superman, and
Suicide Squad before it, Justice League's
score on the site points to an overall consensus
that critics just don't really like the movie
overall.
While fans of the DCEU might not put much
stock in what the critics have to say, general
audiences might start staying away from DC-based
movies in the future, and that will hurt Warner
Bros.' ability to continue expanding its cinematic
universe.
In fact, news hit shortly before Justice League
premiered that WB's execs have put production
of the Flash's long-delayed solo movie on
pause while they wait to see what happens
with its team-up film.
And there's a Joker-focused movie in the works
that will apparently be separate from the
current slate of interconnected movies.
The implications are clear: Warner Bros. is
hedging its bets, and might not be all that
committed to delivering on the teases that
show up in Justice League at all.
After all, the end of Dark Knight Rises sure
seemed to indicate that there was plenty of
room for another batch of movies starring
a new guy as Batman.
And DC even tried once before Man of Steel
to kickstart its cinematic universe with Green
Lantern — and we all remember how that turned
out.
"I know, right?"
Just because we're five movies deep doesn't
mean that Warner Bros. will keep the DCEU
alive — at least not in its current form.
It's already got several different interconnected
superhero universes going on network TV, all
while these movies with the same characters
played by different actors are competing for
fans' affection.
In the end, Warner Bros. doesn't need to keep
this universe alive, and if the bad reviews
start to actually affect ticket sales, it
probably won't.
Then again, we're still getting Fast and the
Furious movies despite half of them being
certified rotten...so you never know.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus, check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too.